I'm Ria Khan I am going to be a stunt  woman  [Music]  my sister Lena is the only person who  believes in me want to help me with the  vid for my channel  that was Doppler but lately she's been  seeing this guy who I think is a bit of  a smarmy wanker  you know it's a truck oh my God we are  chill out now I'm not being dramatic  [Music]  but these people are evil  I found something  with my eye on you they are not taking  her away without a fight  I will strike down you or anyone else  who tries to get in my way  [Music]  to pick area  Let's Dance  [Music]  we need to get Lena  [Music]  outfit  Nina's not going anywhere  [Music]  [Applause]  mom what are you doing now  [Music]  nothing changes  we are going to show Rina who these  people really are  calling me crazy  did you see my kick of course I bloodied  it it was magical  I'm pretty sure I drew blood